I don't know because I'm not a campaign
stretch I mean I would be just a
terrible campaign manager most
journalists would so you know I my take
on that is not better than many other
people's and I don't I don't readily
accept the explanation the idea popular
that has great currency on the blogs or
online that if you stick to your
principles and stand up and and
articulate them strongly no matter what
they are people will back you because
it's really just an election about
people who are Democrats and people who
are Republicans and it's a matter of how
many of them you bring out right this is
the this is the theory the Karl Rove
made popular and that a lot of the folks
that move on and elsewhere think makes a
lot of sense that basically the country
now falls into two camps there's not
that much of a middle ground and the
more full throated you are in defense of
your principles and policies the greater
chance you have of inspiring the people
you need to win I more would subscribe
to Bill Clinton's model that that in
fact campaigns are still decided by
independent voters and those independent
voters you know some of them may have
voted Republican for 15 years without
interruption it doesn't make them
Republicans when you go out and talk to
voters I have in the exurbs or in some
of the rural country's rural states in
the country they're not they're not as
party identified as they used to be
people are just less party identified
they're not they don't see themselves
instruments of a blue team or a red team
they're actually up for grabs but they
can fall into one camp or another for a
significant period of time and and so
you know I think to win particularly for
Democrats from the math is not has not
been especially good up until this
moment the polling is much better for
them right now but I think that's a
reflection of how people are feeling
about Republicans you know you do need
to have a compelling case for people who
don't automatically agrees